hello everyone Bensimon is back and so
is strategy session today I'll be your
host
Dennis Porsche Grand Master resident all
right so today we're going to watch the
great great great great great great
great predecessors of cousin and Caruana
[Music]
now if we think about the opening efore
ePHI tonight a three-night of six who
are the first people we think about so
who was the Cuban genius capablanca and
who was his American rival Marshall
Thank You Ben sorry
it is the Marshall e4 e5 Knight f3
Knight f6 Knight takes e5 d 693 now not
everyone loves the funky move Knight d3
people who love that is rapport and
Carlson but capablanca plays Knight f3
Knight takes e4 and if you remember the
Khurana
March in the candidates you know what
move was played over and over again here
can anyone guess what was the move
what was the game Kramnik Caruana from
the candidates so it starts off as
queenie to queenie 7d three and guess
who played this idea first in like the
highest practice in chess obviously
Capablanca and Marshall and after Knight
f6 Bishop g5 a long struggle capablanca
did prevail so what's fascinating that
even though this game is played in the
1900s you're still following the
footsteps of capablanca and Marshall so
let's head back to the game he played d4
d5 Bishop d3 and Marshall played Bishop
g4 now another interesting quiz question
was coming up which move is the Marshall
attack in this very line it's actually
kuranes favorite
yes Bishop d6 so it's played by Fabi
billions of times what one of the most
interesting games he played was against
Anand even though he lost it was a
fascinating fight and he had his chances
so this move Bishop d6 is actually
called the Marshall variation on
Marshall attack so Bishop g4 Castle
knight c6 rook e1 and here Marshall
played f5 and actually here there's a
better move does anybody know what the
main line is in this line
it's actually not that hard well the
black King is a bit Aires us
yeah Bishop e7 of course and that's what
Capablanca suggested after the game and
just so you know how much the next
generation learned from Capablanca and
marshall the players in 1984 Moscow was
Kasparov and Karpov which continued c4
Knight f6 Knight c3 and this was like a
heat heated debate if this position is
great for black or is it survivable and
after some very very exciting games
it seemed that Kasparov managed to win
few of them so this is kind of like
under some cloud but it's still an
interesting line so there's a lot of
lively play left in this position so
anyways
Marshall is an innovator so Bishop e7
seemed like yeah just a regular move so
you played f5 which looks very exciting
but not necessarily too good so how did
couple Blanca try to punish him well as
you can see this Knight is pretty stable
because of these pawns
you really need to undermine this beast
on e4 do you have any chances of an
advantage
how can you potentially undermine this
square I mean this piece yes
c4 yes of course c4 and Marshall plays
his favorite move Bishop d6 and now we
have to decide how to continue notice
that black is just a move away from
castling so if he manages to do that
whew you're in deep trouble so we do
have to be careful here
we should just follow the game plan and
take bishop takes so he says I will have
lively peace peace play and you will
have trouble actually using the fact
that I'm not yet Castle so Marshall
decides to take on f3 Queen takes f3 the
reason he doesn't take on f3 with the
pawn it's kind of simple cuz Queen h4
it's kind of dangerous
there's too many threats and you didn't
want to chance that also Bishop takes h2
is annoying because you can't take this
cuz check Queen takes F 2 and if black
really wants to can repeat but there's
no guarantees you don't get checkmated
here because this King is very very weak
here and h1 so kapa decides to take on
f3 Knight takes d4 you know this is
again a very critical position here
there would you bring your queen keep in
mind that your biggest weaknesses with
white is still the h2 + f2 squares so
you need to keep an eye on those if you
want to be on the safe side if you don't
want to be on the safe side and you
might get into trouble
so where could we potentially bring this
screen that would still be an aggressive
piece while defending some of these
phones h3 that's an idea
but I would be a little bit more
concerned with the f2 pawn yeah
therefore III Queen III and the added
benefit of this move is that she'd
defend this pawn and you attack the d4
and e4 Knight this is a pretty nice
multi-purpose move and black here comes
up with a creative solution Queen f6
takes takes Queen takes e4 and king f7
now King d7 would run into queen g4
check that's why it's not a great idea
and to be honest with you I assume that
Marshall had this planned out up till
here but here capablanca comes up with
ingenious solution which basically
destroys Frank Marshalls concept
first we need to identify blacks threats
in there pretty brutal
what are those yes so this square is
kind of weak notice that my queen and
rook is lined up that's not always a
good thing what can black potentially do
here yes
rook e8 is like a huge threat and if
that happens you're in big trouble
so we need to come up with a radical
solution yeah both both dis rook and the
other rook is strengthening
so if I just play my Knight to c3 is
that helping me much not at all so the
main concept that capablanca is using in
his next move is distraction and that
will help untangle his position just
treat this position as part of puzzle
rush you might enjoy it yes
yeah Bishop g5 yeah so what's the idea
behind Bishop g5 because we found a move
but and we are distracting the Queen
from defending this d4 Knight but what
is the point of it because that's one of
the issues that might faced but also
solves two problems at the same time yes
exactly so for one the Queen is
distracted from defending this pawn I
mean this is distracted from defending
this Knight and also our queen will be
able to move away so Queen takes g5
Queen takes d4 and now Rukia doesn't do
anything special you just need to make
one very nice move here which is simple
what very strong and it is Knight c3
it's very nice when you can develop your
piece and also connect your rooks that
usually is a sign that everything is
under control
King g8 and this is one of those rare
cases when Marshalls natural move is not
as good as a concrete move would be this
was Marshalls last chance to get some
play against White's position
how could black try to put a little bit
of pressure on d5 indirectly
well first off who's up material is it
even whites up upon so if you're behind
in your black what you're supposed to do
if you have less material and you're
heading towards lots of trading in the
end there might be insufficient material
right so keeping that in mind what
should be Marshalls best chance in this
position it should be five that the idea
yeah yeah that's an idea that's a
creative idea what Marshall should have
played as queen f4 and the idea is to
get rid of this really good queen on d4
because our queen was really not doing
anything on g5 so after the exchanges
he's forced to otherwise the h2 pawn is
dropping the black Bishop suddenly
becomes monstrous and way better than
the c3 Knight even if we let's say try
to chase it away it might go to d2 or
even to e5 and when it enters there
black might have some counter play
against this d5 pawn so I'm not even
sure if black is much worse here like
has real fighting chances to make a draw
but what I guess happened is that
marshal God dejected by Kappa Blancas
wonderful ideas like Bishop g5 and
Knight c3 and he thought that okay this
is not gonna work out well for me so I
might as well put my King into safety
but now seeing this capablanca chases
the Queen away Queen eight six and here
he plays a very powerful defensive move
so a couple Blanca doesn't really like
the fact that the Queen and the bishop
is festering that h2 poem so he finds a
pawn move that will get rid of that
issue forever yes the big dilemma here
is indeed if you want to play pawn g3 or
pawn to h3 the big question is obviously
does h3 solve the bishop Queen duo
putting pressure on the h2 square in the
upcoming future or not yeah probably not
yeah so g3 and exactly that's why capo
played g3 because if you play h3 as I
mentioned the Queen might hop to f4 and
you're just getting looser on the Kings
side so g3 stopping all these funny
business on the Kings side and now black
is basically waiting to get destroyed
rook d8 and you don't have to ask up a
Blanca twice he takes that pawn Bishop
b4 rookie three notice that whatever a
cup of Blanca does he makes sure that
all of his pieces are defended okay it's
true that his queen is far away but you
can be a hundred percent certain
he knew that it's not gonna get trapped
rook d5 doesn't work cuz there's nice
little tactics of Knight f6 just ends
the game because I take then I take your
rook and it's over
so basically Marshall has to stall play
to be six and what do you think up a
Blanca did here
play simple chest lie kappa blanka it's
just the simplest move possible yes yeah
just take c7 yes
he's upon grubber rook c8 Queen d7 he's
not scared he knows that he will
eventually escape on the white squares
green g6 but notice that Marshall is
trying trying to come up with some
counter place but capablanca is not
impressed plays d6 broke the 8 Queen c7
rook c8 and rook c8 was a big mistake it
turns out and couple Blanca just takes
the point home but how did he do it
comes up with a very neat little idea
here should we move our queen maybe you
have other options Knight f6 doesn't
work yet because I take with upon and
least I don't see direct win yes d7 yes
yes yes exactly
so d7 is the killer move that couple
Blanca found and maybe even Knight f6
could work here but this is more
dangerous to choose this move move order
but as we know capablanca knows when to
choose the cleanest options and that
therefore he played these seven although
the idea is exactly the same so takes
takes Knight f6 takes Rukia King f7
rookie to and he managed to beat Frank
Marshall in this game alright so I want
to show two very very good games played
by capablanca that follows the same
strategy
slowly slowly taking away the breathing
space for his from his opponents so this
game was played against coop chick whom
you don't know much about but he plays
e4 e5 Knight f3 knight c6 and can
anybody tell me what was Kappa Blancas
favorite opening against e4 e5
in general
it is the four nights that he loved to
play and what he played really really
well
Knight c3 Knight f6 Bishop b5 they
should be four now this should be four
is not the only move here and in fact
the other move might even be stronger
can anyone tell me what is the other
option here than many many super
grandmasters adopted since it's the
shocking move Knight d4 because black
can't take on Mike I'm sorry
white can't take on e5 because it runs
into tactical ideas like Queen e7 9 f3
but then black can take here Queen takes
e4 Queen e2 takes takes Knight d5 and c4
sadly doesn't win because a6 ruins all
the fun
that's actually the tactical
justification of akeeba Rubenstein's
idea of 94 which became popular later
even though he invented around this time
but many many people still play Bishop
b4 castles castles and you're in
strategy session so capablanca tries to
create an inferior structure for his
opponent the ship takes D 6 D takes c6
d3 now can anybody tell me if this
structure is familiar from other
openings or not yes
yeah this is very much similar to thee
Bishop takes c6 Spanish and also to the
sub variations of Berlin defense where
they play during d3 where they play d3
early and cup check obviously not that
familiar with this type of play plays
rook e8 even though probably he should
pin the knight right now ship g4 because
that will be annoying and h3 g4 just
would weaken the King Kings position and
roof chick would get good chances there
but he plays rook e8 and now capablanca
starts restricting his opponents
possibilities how did he do that just
stage three of course the point being
that this bishop will be miserable there
forever
that's why lack needed to play Bishop g4
as early as possible so cope chick
decides to take on c3 which in hint side
I don't think is a good idea because
before that at least he had two bishops
which is a plus cuz as the position
opens up things might get rosier for
black but after taking on c3
we're going to have an intricate
opposite colored bishop middle game
Queen b6 9h for now Knight h4 is
planning the idea of jumping to f5 but
also stops Knight age five ideas
so what capablanca is doing there is
he's trying to follow his own plan while
restricting all of the options that
black would be looking for so koopchick
has to play g6 which might be a little
bit risky
as in the future blacks kingside might
be weak
F for obviously cup of Blanca is not
scared to give up on because let's say
at age five but if let's say Queen c5
check King h1 takes
rugby one Bishop b2 is coming and if you
for some reason you would take Bishop b2
would even immediately wind and I don't
have six and if you win pieces that
quickly and easily that means your
concept was way better than your
opponents that shows how strong cup of
Blanco was and is so F for not h5 f
takes e5 he knows that he has to open up
the position for the bishop Queen takes
e5 Queen f3 Bishop e6 g4 now g4 seems
edgy but there's so many defenders on
the King side that there's no real risk
pushing that pawn and also the position
is semi closed so it's very unlikely
that you're gonna get made it here
unless something horrible happens so 97
rugby 1 notice that Capablanca cheekily
gives the option of taking on c3 go
ahead eat that poison apple b6 c4 and
have any of you played the nimzo-indian
before a little bit so you might be able
to notice that capablanca wilfully puts
all of his pawns on white squares just
the polar opposite of his bishop so it
can move really wild restricting the
opponent's bishop so h5 there for h5
might be a little dubious in the sense
black should try to stay put and wait
because eventually this bishop will
enter this long diagonal and dead
we'll be decisive g5 king h7
although h5 I think is a little bit iffy
at least he could put the King on h7
which could help him bring the rook to
g8 and you know he can't hold his
position together for a while not saying
it will last forever but at least he can
fight King G - no rush that can't really
do anything anyways Queen d6 and indeed
black is just waiting but should be -
and the dragon entered the position rook
g8 obviously a very good move now it's
hard to get close to the g7 night so
therefore a couple Blanca starts slowly
maneuvering around Queen III can anybody
tell me what could be the potential idea
of Queen e3 what could be the plan of
capablanca yes yes doubling the rooks on
her father's correct and also maybe
hinting a little bit on c5 because it's
always nice to give your opponent a
triple pawn so black is not excited
about that idea place Queen d7 a3 just
just protecting everything c5 and notice
black is trying to do the same thing as
couple Blanca did he's putting all the
points that he could on dark squares the
opposite of the e6 bishop so Brooke f6
very nice planning maybe some future
sacrifices on g6 also putting pressure
on e6 Bishop 98 rook f4 and you can
notice that black is uncomfortable he's
chasing the Rockaways saying go away the
this is going to be too much pressure if
we leave it like this
okay 496 now maybe this wasn't such a
great idea by black because the knight
was at least
offending some of these crucial pieces
and on d6 it just defends the f7 point
you need to defend that pawn as well but
h5 & e6 might be more critical rook F
698 you know this is just probing and
capablanca is not going to go and for a
three time repetition and make a draw
row b8 rook F 1 B 5 C 2 X B 5 c4 a 4 so
here black went ballistic he couldn't
stand still any longer and said okay
whatever I'm going to do some action on
the Queen side before I lose on the
Kings side so if you would have done
Knight d6 there's some funny ideas here
like Queen f3 let's say b5 rook f6 and B
takes e4 actually will lose here how
does black blues after B takes e4
yes
well if you play if I take the bishop
yes yes and I take route 86 checkmate
that's very elegant and I'm sure kappa
blanka would have been happy to execute
this finish but sadly he wasn't given
the chance would be one is opponent
played B 5c takes c4 a4 a6 d4 so notice
that he's trying to restrict the white
white squared bishop here he doesn't
really care as much about the pawns as
much as he cares about pushing his
opponent down the board and this d5 idea
is just just d5 ideas just super strong
here so it takes the 5 notice he doesn't
really care about the pawns he just
wants to push it all the way now sadly
black has to take he takes Queen d5 King
G 1 B takes a four rook takes f7 9 g7
Bishop takes g7 and this is just
basically agony rook takes you seven
takes takes Knight takes g6 still he has
the Flair he could just go Queen e7
check and would win but Knight takes g6
is very stylish he can't really take
because I would play rook f6 Queen e7
and checkmate to follow like in GA check
mean g7 checkmate
so rugby 697 greeny 6 green d4 g6 green
earth for black resign that's a very
nice display of powerful chest by
Capablanca and all he did this game was
restriction he tried to improve his
position while restricting all of the
mobility of the black pieces especially
notice that the white square bishop had
nowhere to go the whole game alright so
last but not least I wanted to show this
game between Steiner Herman and
Capablanca Steiner headman is very
famous actually he's here in the World
Chess Hall of Fame he's up there on the
wall because he's very famous for
establishing the Hollywood chess group
where he thought Humphrey Bogart Lauren
Bacall Billy Wilder so he was a very
very famous chess player already when
they played also he was an American
champion another interesting tidbit
about him is that in 1945 there was a
USA USSR so us a Soviet match radio
match played and only one guy beat
Soviet player and that was Herman
Steiner he beat Bondarev ski one and a
half half which is a big big result and
you'll see that the quality of this game
is very high and let's get into this he
45 what a shock
four nights it should be five Bishop b4
castle castle d3 the six Bishop g5 this
is the old mainline Bishop takes c3
otherwise Knight d5 would come and
because of this pin this would be very
very uncomfortable h6 would be a
terrible bunt blunder because I take
take oh that would be bad as well but if
you take with the Queen
the problem is I attack both both the
Queen and the bishop you have to move
the Queen but I take on c6 I take on b4
and I'm a piece up so this is very
pleasant for white but Steiner is or
will be become if we look at from 1933 a
u.s. champion so he's not that weak
he takes Bishop takes c3 he wants to get
rid of that night forever B takes c3 in
97 now later on they came up with this
idea of Queen e7 and if we think about
strategic play what could be the
strategic idea behind Queen e7 think
about a plan of chasing this Bishop away
this Bishop away what could be the plan
of black so black has this very
interesting idea of 98 and mayor would
that night go from there g6 right I'm
just hitting the bishop for example I
just give you a sample line 98 D 496 now
you can't take on e5 too many times
because this Bishop will still be
hanging this Bishop will still be
hanging here so White has to move the
bishop but then Knight f4 comes and
after a long journey it will enter on g6
and black is really happy here so that's
an idea that they came out way way later
but Steiners move 97 is actually the
best move in this position which many
people didn't play for awhile just
shocking because capablanca immediately
found the best move here
and that's why not a seven was kind of
in a shadow because of this game
remember Capablanca wants to restrict
and if we know that he wants to restrict
you might wonder what he's trying to
stop each three well age three would
stop this Bishop on CA to ever going to
g4 but why did black move the knight to
e7 what is the plan for black there yes
c6 d5 is part of the plan but the main
plan is different where is this Knight
headed - yes headed to g6 so the only
thing that we need to find now is the
restricting move
yes and this is clearly the best move
which is astounding that computers show
this is the best one in couple Blanca
didn't even have a computer and he knew
that this should be the right move
because the main point is the knight g6
is not that good cuz I can take and
stuff I can take here and if you have to
take with H you'll never get rid of this
beast on g5 if you take with F just look
at your structure it's very bad and also
in the future white is going to build a
center of at f3 and d4 and you also have
the bishop pair so therefore as you just
mentioned he goes c6 ship c4 and Bishop
e6 now the correct move is d5 and that's
what Steiner should have played but
obviously we're in the early stages of
up opening knowledge so they didn't know
what the move is here and d5 is clearly
a computer move which didn't occur to
Steiner at the time now d5 would be a
good move and clean d6 and this is
probably the best defense for black and
this is still a position that people
debate right now as well but China
didn't know it and played Bishop e6 and
after Capablanca saw that my G 6 is not
going to be an issue
he's ready to ruin the structure for
black Bishop takes f6 G takes f6 Bishop
takes c6 f takes c6 and now we should
find a plan to put big pressure on
blacks position
note is that this ecig spawn is super
weak right now in capablanca doesn't
hesitate to strike yes green g4 of
course forcing the king to move up and
defend the e6 pawn which nobody really
likes to do the king would be happier
here on h8 thanks king f7 how can we use
this unfortunate situation of the black
king well Queen h5 King g7 mm-hmm he
started with f4 group g8 and now he did
the same thing so being h5 was like an
alternative probably he didn't do that
because he was quite happy attacking the
e6 pawn for the moment so he waited till
his opponent decided to attack the Queen
that's why he started with f4 rook g8
now Queen h5 check now also an IG 6
doesn't work because f5 and it's it's
very annoying especially as you're
losing the piece so black was forced to
play King g7 half takes e5 d takes e5
and now kappa blanka comes up with a
brilliant finish it's white to move and
when puzzle rush number 2 well the first
move seems simple right
yeah obviously rook takes f6 black has
to capture Oh what were you thinking
what else what are the moves
King h8 well that would be admitting
that this is brilliant you can't really
do that because I can't just take you
and I have lots of lots of pieces so
King takes f6 that's the critical one
yeah look f1 now we have a choice for
black either King g7 or Knight f5 which
one seems more reasonable Knight f5 yeah
I think also not Knight f5 is the better
one and that's what Steiner played
matter v King g7 has some issues what's
the issue here cleaning 7 I go to the
corner King h8 and I'm not sure you can
make yeah so rook f7 is the cleanest way
and here and okay let's take with the
rook yeah this looks nicer I guess so
Knight f5 is the move in here couple
Blanca again shines because his next
move is very elegant
he takes with the night
which is very nice because even he takes
f5 is winning but 9f5 is a forced win
Black has to take Queen b6 would do no
good because I call check and you lose
so he takes that 5 has to be played here
and you know if we're even just a little
bit party people we will play real takes
at 5
now King g7 loses the same way right
it's just rook f7 King h8 checkmate King
g7 was played and shockingly the best
move here is not rook f7 but Queen f7
check King d6 and you'll have to
continue chasing how should we continue
that chase because at first glance this
seems like black averted the biggest
danger but it's not so
so probably what's the first move
yes you should say rook f6 yes yes okay
f6 is the move I mean I do understand
that you might fear of me taking right
but that's not a big deal I get lots of
pawns
so King see if I was played but if black
takes I take and anywhere you're trying
to hide I take this and I'll have plenty
of bonds and this should be should be
easily winning so also Steiner might
have been optimistic here and played
king c5 and now a couple Blanca plays a
move that it's kind of astonishing even
though I'm not saying it's the hardest
move ever but it's still a pretty good
move
would even say it's like simple but
spectacular
yes what if I take on f6 yes
so Queen takes b7 and he played Queen b6
but if Queen takes f6 even though your
life 50 rooks up I play Queen B for and
no place for you to go as I own them all
but Steiner played Queen b6 hope for the
best but here comes the biggest shock of
all and that is rook takes c6 and
shockingly after Queen takes c6 Queen me
for finished at all the very very nice
game by capablanca against Herman
Steiner and to be honest with you I'm
very impressed with this game and also
in general his strategic game what he
showed in both this game again Steiner
and cope chick as he showed that after
restricting your opponent's pieces you
can be ready to sacrifice as many pieces
as you want because you already defeated
your open and strategically just look at
those two rooks here they're stuck there
doing nothing and all because the white
played that helped him to restrict all
of the black pieces I think that's why
couple Blancas play is just superb thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]